Indiana Jones in a dial of Destiny
it's okay
but not great
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV a
movie channel
[Music]
so a really good friend of the channel
was at cams and they got to see the full
final edit of Indiana Jones and the dial
of Destiny now YouTube has been a light
with basically criticizing this movie
for 12 months and telling us all that it
was going to be a load of rubbish now
finally as I say a very close friend of
the channel has got to see the final
result and he's been able to give me his
verdict
and
he said it's not bad
it's just not great so as you know if
you've been on Twitter and you've been
following some of the
more negative comments about the movie
you'll know that there's been lots of
stuff said one of the things said was
that there were several reshoots doing
that there were several endings to the
film shot and re-shot and that basically
it was considered to be a little bit of
a hot mess now James Mangold the guy
that actually directed the movies come
out and said look a lot of this stuff
just ain't true there's lots of people
out there pretending to have sources
that are basically saying this that and
the other and it's just not true John
Williams who did the amazing musical
score for this movie and my guy that has
actually seen the film says it is
properly amazing did come out in an
interview and say that they were
reshooting the end of the movie now
Mangold has said that's just not true he
was either mistaken or misquoted or
whatever and that the filming has
actually gone ahead quite smoothly this
is just one major example about how a
big project like this does attract and
all a lot of negativity and I would urge
anybody including the fans of Sidetrack
that are going to now listen to
basically my review of a film I've not
actually seen but again I've spoken to
somebody that has
to actually wait and watch the film for
themselves but let's get to the point
what did my guy with no spoilers say
about the film first of all he basically
said don't do not compare this to The
Originals don't don't compare to the
first three films anyway if you want to
compare it to the Crystal Skull it comes
out favorably it's better than that but
if you compare it to even the Last
Crusade
um definitely the Temple of Doom
it doesn't come out well this film is
not as good as those three Classics for
lots and lots of reasons
he said the story wanders a little bit
he said that he felt like in the editor
and the director just weren't on the
same page at times that it felt like
you're building towards one thing and
then it just cuts away and goes in
another Direction and at times the
storyline that does jump through time a
little bit is confusing and you don't
necessarily always understand exactly
where the emphasis of certain plots is
going there is an injection of humor in
this movie that maybe the Crystal Skull
again lacked getting back to the
classics of the first Indiana Jones
movies or at least that's what they were
trying to do he basically said that it
felt very much like the writers were
trying too hard to make this an Indiana
Jones films and to have Indiana Jones
jokes he said that these jokes felt a
little awkward at times like they were
forced now I am imagining what he's
saying here is that a lot of these jokes
are put in maybe before the story was
written so instead of creating jokes
around the story that made sense they
sort of tried to work scenes around
certain jokes that they thought worked
as Indie jokes now I think we've seen
that type of thing before on sequels
where certain references or certain
jokes are only there to make you think
about the Nostalgia of what you're
watching
rather than having jokes comments
references that make sense to the story
this is a trap that I think Hollywood
has fallen into a million times before
and will fall into a million times again
the one benefit he did say was that the
special effects in this movie genuinely
were brilliant when he basically
summarized this film to me he said a
very expensive and you can see the money
on the screen the de-aging effects with
Harrison Ford are some of the best he's
ever seen and we know this from the
adverts I've seen it myself they are
brilliant he said the special effects
particularly in the sort of build up
towards the finale are
amazing bordering on the ridiculous and
he says the actual story building up to
the finale is just as ridiculous as the
effects but they stay just this side of
getting stupid I've seen a couple of
reviews that basically say the end of
this film they really swung for the
fences and my guy basically agreed he
said they built up to do something truly
incredible but unfortunately they miss
by just a nanometer that they don't
quite hit the extraordinary levels that
they promised and then really the end of
the film Falls a little flat I asked him
why do you think that was why do you
think it really lost that energy at the
end and he says it was Grandeur over
substance that they wanted it to look
incredible and massive and big but they
forgot to have the substance of the
story there that it maybe didn't quite
fulfill the promise of how it looked
with what it was actually saying so I
asked a simple question is this a
fitting goodbye if it is in fact a
goodbye to one of the most iconic
characters in all of Cinema Indiana
Jones
his answer a damn site more than a
crystal skull was so you know he is
actually quite pleased that they've
created this film after the I'm gonna
say cluster of the Indians Crystal
school movie I won't swear I'll be nice
the Crystal Skull film to me
was just a mess from beginning to end
from the ants the size of dogs to the
ridiculous storylines to the nuclear
weapon going off that somehow Indiana
Jones survived being thrown two or three
miles and roll just the rolling never
mind the radiation just that fridge
rolling that far would have liquidized
anything inside it and he just gets out
and goes and walks off
that's that's just stupid the film
forgot what it was to be Indiana Jones
that yes it's ridiculous at times yes
it's extraordinary at times but yes it
was still based on some sort of reality
Indiana Jones from the Crystal Skull was
like the Fast and the Furious of the
Indiana Jones movies it forgot what
realism was and just went into the
stupid
and that was always a massive
disappointment I asked him does this
film suffer from the same fate and he
said at times yeah at times because of
CGI Etc they go into the stupid at times
this movie borderline's Becoming a
cartoon and that's not what you want in
that sort of film so is it fitting
goodbye no
unfortunately though after the
Brilliance of the first three films and
basically the classic nature of the
character it's almost impossible to have
a fitting goodbye to him you can't
create a movie that is ever going to be
quite as perfect as The Originals even
really the only way they could have done
that was to not make Indiana Jones four
and five to have left it with the Last
Crusade as I think that was the plan at
the time because Indiana Jones and the
Last Crusade was the fitting goodbye to
this character and it really is a shame
that in the search for money
and maybe a little bit of nostalgia they
maybe have left a slight bitter taste in
the mouth of moviegoers and in the mouth
of Indiana Jones real fans I asked him
about the five minute standing ovation
at the end of the movie he basically
said look a lot of that was aimed at
Harrison Ford because he is actually
brilliant in this movie he's brilliant
in most movies a lot of the storyline
again without any spoilers is about him
getting towards the end of his life and
basically how he doesn't really feel
relevant anymore
the way they actually work that into the
storyline and the way they resolve in
the end he said was actually quite
beautiful he actually said coming out of
that you do feel a positivity towards
the character
so the standard Ovation aimed at
Harrison Ford he said it was quite an
awkward Standing Ovation though he said
you're clapping in all the time you're
looking to see who's going to stop
clapping first so you can stop now he
said at the Cannes Film Festival when
you get big premieres like this a
five-minute standard Ovation is actually
not that much he said he's been to
several of these premieres and this is
that really was nothing for them that
was you know
bye compared to other standard Ovations
he's witnessed
and he said but the feel of the stand
Innovation it was what he said was quite
striking because you almost felt awkward
at around the third minute that actually
you would just Pander into the people on
the stage rather than actually
celebrating a movie so in a nutshell
this film's okay it's not a bad movie
it's nothing like as bad as a lot of
people on YouTube have been screaming
for the last 12 months is the film that
stands up against Indiana Jones and the
Raiders of the Lost Ark God no but we
can really make the argument
is Hollywood even capable of that
anymore
I'm not sure but guys get to the
comments and tell me what you think you
haven't seen the film yet so don't tell
me it's a load of rubbish but you can
tell me your expectations do you expect
it to be a load of rubbish or are you
actually quite looking forward to it I
can tell you that I put a poll on the
channel just about an hour ago it's only
at 27 votes up till now but I asked are
you looking forward to the Indiana Jones
are you actually looking forward to one
last crack of the whip even though I've
written one must crack of the whip I do
really need to start checking these
things before I hit the send button but
41 of people say yes they're looking
forward to it 50 of people say no and 10
of people say yeah I'm undecided it does
seem that there's already a fair bit of
negativity around the Indiana Jones
movie and that's a shame but to be fair
in this case they might be right
so get in the comments and tell me
exactly what you're thinking about this
movie I'd love to know who's going to go
to the cinema to watch it because this
is one of those films you can only
really appreciate on the really big
screen
and guys if we don't keep going to the
cinema
we're not going to have Cinemas to go to
in the next decade so please get to the
cinema and watch this film
I am absolutely certain there are bits
of it you're going to love even if you
do come away maybe a little disappointed
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
you'll never miss any of our new videos
also you can go to patreon.com forward
slash sidetrackware for a small
contribution each month that really
supports the channel you can see most of
our videos first and without the adverts
as always please stay safe and I'll see
you next time
thank you